so kamala harris has many flacks not
just at the vp's office but throughout
the media wants you to know that despite
being super unpopular she's hard at work
the san francisco chronicle is reporting
that quote kamala harris has redecorated
the vp's office here's the meaning
behind her choices now the first thing
you should know is that kamala harris
has
horrible taste don't let her near your
house
but the second thing you should know is
that only a supine groveling media could
produce coverage like this
miranda devine is a connoisseur of
coverage like this she mocks it
mercilessly at the new york post she
joins us tonight to do the same we're in
it it's so great to see you so congrats
on your book by the way which is just
absolutely killing it and deserves to
um
let me ask you
kamala harris redecorating an office and
making it uglier is a news story
well apparently so and you know it's
pretty rare to get a one-on-one
interview with kamala harris and the san
francisco chronicle to their great
credit managed to score one
but they didn't ask her apparently about
the border crisis about the two million
illegal migrants that have come over
under her aegis this is supposed to be
something she's fixing apparently there
was nothing to talk about that it was
all about you know the shade of blue
that she'd repainted the walls
she's replaced apparently some patterned
couches with some pristine white ones uh
and she also um
you know she has a lot of artwork on her
walls and so the san francisco chronicle
went into great detail telling us all
about you know there's a painting called
white daisy rhapsody behind her desk
wait can i ask you a question she's this
feminist leader she's breaking glass
ceiling she's inspiring america's women
my daughters
and yet the one interview she gives is
about interior decorating
yeah it look it's pretty sexist really
when you think about it she should be up
in arms
but that's what she's all about she's
all about trivia and frivolity and she
never wants to talk about anything
serious like the border no plan to visit
no plan to fix it no it's all about her
decor
ah amazing randy divine author of a
brand new book on hunter biden's laptop
the person who's on the story from the
beginning the book is killing it and
deserves to
we recommend it random great to see you
thank you
thanks tucker hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else